[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'entretien de France 24 notre invité
aujourd'hui est la directrice générale
de l'UNESCO madame Audrey Azoulay
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
bonjour à vous merci nous sommes Adèle
en Grèce à l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire de la Convention sur le
patrimoine mondial convention adoptée
donc en 1972 d'Elf c'est tout un symbole
selon la mythologie grecque c'est ici
que Zeus a créé le nombril du monde un
lieu qui incarne aussi l'esprit de cette
convention sur le patrimoine mondial à
l'occasion de ce cinquantenaire quel est
le bilan que vous faites aujourd'hui
d'abord c'est vrai que c'est une chance
merveilleuse de pouvoir fêter ici à
Delphes dans cet endroit magnifique avec
une tradition de rencontre philosophique
culturelles c'est magnifique de pouvoir
le fêter ici on nous fêtons 50 ans d'un
texte qui est né
à Paris en novembre 1972 avec cette idée
qui était une idée nouvelle d'avoir des
normes communes pour la communauté
internationale pour la protection du
patrimoine l'UNESCO vous le savez est né
bien avant cela juste après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale sur les cendres morales
et physiques de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale avec l'idée de défendre la paix
par la culture par l'éducation par les
sciences par la liberté d'informer aussi
et l'idée de patrimoine au début n'était
pas la première et elle s'est peu à peu
imposée aussi avec de grandes réussites
à l'époque par exemple pour préserver
les temples d'aboucibel et les autres
qui étaient
en Nubie avant même l'existence de la
convention ou pour protéger la lagune de
Venise et en 1972 il y a eu ce moment
fondateur où les États se sont mis
ensemble et ont décidé de s'engager pour
protéger le patrimoine mondial alors
c'est bien sûr en 50 ans cette liste des
sites du patrimoine mondial qui est qui
a rencontré un succès extraordinaire
mais c'est aussi et surtout un droit
d'énormes des mécanismes de protection
nationaux qui sont nés et aussi un
succès universel puisqu'il y a 194 états
c'est énorme qui ont ratifié cette
convention et qui se sont donc engagés à
connaître ce patrimoine à l'étudier
scientifiquement et surtout à le
protéger et le transmettre
et qu'est-ce que vous répondez justement
à cette critique qu'on entend
régulièrement sur le label patrimoine
mondial concrètement une inscription au
Patrimoine mondial ce n'est pas juste un
une jolie plaque décorative qu'on
affiche à l'entrée d'un site reconnu non
c'est surtout pas ça et il est vrai
qu'il y a certains sites qui sont
victimes de surtourisme c'est un
problème majeur qui qui vient détériorer
en réalité les sites du patrimoine
mondial et c'est ce pourquoi nous nous
sommes engagés à aider les États à avoir
des stratégies d'abord de
diversification de leur tourisme mais
aussi d'une gestion plus durable ça peut
être des tickets horodatés ça peut être
de limiter le nombre de visiteurs sur un
site il y a de multiples façons de le
faire ça peut être comme à Venise ou
après des années de discussion nous
avons finalement obtenu que les méga
navires de croisière ne puissent plus
accoster dans la lagune mais en réalité
ça c'est un
problème qui doit pas masquer plus
l'étendue des succès par ailleurs qui
est justement cet engagement à préserver
parfois à reconstruire aussi ou à
réhabiliter je pense par exemple à au
temple d'Angkor au Cambodge c'est des
temples qui avaient été minées au sens
littéral et détruit par la guerre et qui
ont été reconstruits grâce à la
coopération internationale que permet
cette Convention du patrimoine mondial
donc il y a aussi des endroits qui
renessent grâce à cette convention et
qui sont un site de nouveau accessible
pour les générations futures c'est aussi
le même esprit qui nous a conduit plus
récemment à lancer une grande opération
pour la vieille ville de Mossoul donc on
voit bien que c'est aussi une dynamique
vertueuse de protection de connaissances
de transmission mais qu'il faut gérer
absolument la question du sur tourisme
comme la question d'ailleurs du
changement climatique qui le met aussi
en péril justement j'allais venir le
changement climatique c'est aujourd'hui
la menace principale pour les sites
reconnus au patrimoine mondial vous
venez d'annoncer un plan d'action pour
les 50 prochaines années comment est-ce
que vous comptez relever ce défi de
d'adaptation au dérèglement climatique
déjà la première chose que nous faisons
c'est une fonction de d'alerte nous
avons publié tout récemment une étude
sur par exemple les glaciers qui sont en
train de disparaître qui sont classés au
patrimoine mondial ou les forêts qui
deviennent et maîtrisent de CO2 au lieu
de au lieu de le capter comme elles le
font comme elles le font quand on les
laisse vivre et se déployer
alerter mais aussi permettre des
mécanismes de gestion plus durables avec
un tourisme aussi plus durable qui soit
pas prédateur avec le plastique avec un
certain nombre ou l'exploitation minière
en bordure des sites du Patrimoine un
certain nombre de mesures que nous
voulons faire adopter pour les protéger
mais la première chose à faire pour
arrêter de détruire le patrimoine
mondial c'est de respecter les accords
de Paris et c'est de s'engager dans une
réduction des émissions de CO2 pour
maintenir ce réchauffement climatique
qui est déjà là mais le maintenir dans
des limites qui permettent de préserver
parce que sinon il faut bien comprendre
ce lien entre nature et culture quand on
détruit la planète quand le climat se
dérègle c'est aussi des cultures qui
sont menacées très directement dans leur
existence des sites mais aussi le
patrimoine immatériel mais aussi des
pratiques culturelles mais aussi la vie
des populations locales qui qui vivent
l'Afrique c'est aussi le continent
prioritaire pour l'UNESCO le continent
est aujourd'hui sous-reprété au
patrimoine mondial il représente environ
9% de la totalité des biens inscrits 12
pays n'ont aucun site inscrit comment
est-ce que vous comptez vous y prendre
pour que l'Afrique soit mieux
représentée au patrimoine mondial c'est
un grand défi qui s'est
cristallisée au fil des années de cette
convention et qui nous dit quand même
quelque chose c'est pas normal au bout
de 50 ans on est 27 pays qui n'est aucun
site inscrit
dont 12 en Afrique
et par ailleurs sur le continent
africain beaucoup décident qui sont déjà
inscrits sont passés sur la liste du
Patrimoine en danger donc il faut qu'on
ait absolument
une attention particulière et des
actions volontaristes pour rééquilibrer
ce qui aujourd'hui a déséquilibre
géographique manifeste quel type
d'action par exemple par exemple pour ce
qui relève de l'UNESCO nous avons choisi
d'agir par exemple pour aider à former
les professionnels africains aux
questions du patrimoine de la
conservation de la gestion des sites
c'est quelque chose que nous avons déjà
commencé à faire mais pour lequel nous
essayons de mobiliser aussi la
communauté internationale pour nous
soutenir par des coopérations il y a
beaucoup de demandes venant des États
africains et surtout je voudrais que
nous les accompagnons dans la
préparation de leur dossier pour que
d'ici 2030 c'est 12 états et pu proposer
des candidatures au patrimoine mondial
parce que bien sûr ils ont des sites
tout à fait dignes d'être retenu par
cette liste mais il faut les accompagner
dans l'élaboration des dossiers de
candidature d'abord mais aussi en suite
de gestion de préservation et c'est tout
à fait la vocation de l'UNESCO que de le
faire et vous misez aussi sur la
jeunesse pour qu'elle prenne une part
active dans cette préservation c'est à
eux aussi leur capital et c'est bien
c'est bien la tragédie que nous vivons
qui est de voler le patrimoine qui est
celui de la jeunesse si on le laisse
être détruit par l'ensemble des facteurs
que nous avons que nous avons évoqué
donc il est important pour que la
jeunesse en soit aussi pleinement
propriétaire de ce patrimoine de lui
transmettre avec aussi toutes
l'éducation qui va avec nous allons
étendre un dispositif lancé il y a peu
pour que les écoles puissent avoir
toutes les ressources d'enseignement
pour mieux comprendre et connaître le
patrimoine qui est à la proximité des
sites du patrimoine mondial ce sont
aussi des une forme numérique qui
permettent aujourd'hui une autre façon
d'accéder et au lieu du patrimoine que
nous lançons et que nous souhaitons
universaliser là aussi pour donner à la
jeunesse les clés du patrimoine qui en
réalité et le sien vous comptez donc
mettre les nouvelles technologies au
service de la préservation du patrimoine
mondial à l'image de ce que fait déjà
l'UNESCO grâce au déploiement de
satellites et de drone notamment en
Ukraine et en Afghanistan c'est vraiment
une évolution très intéressante qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec les nouveautés
nouvelle technologie en
Ukraine vous le disiez c'est une zone de
guerre malheureusement et c'est par
satellite en collaboration avec d'autres
agences des Nations Unies que nous
arrivons à suivre de près les sites du
patrimoine mondial situé en Ukraine pour
pouvoir
évaluer les dommages éventuels qui
seraient qui serait malheureusement fait
ou alors pour suivre d'autres sites
culturel en Ukraine mais c'est aussi à
Mossoul des drones qui nous permettaient
de survoler les sites alors que le
déminage n'était pas encore fait cette
en Afghanistan ou un minaret trop penché
et bien nous surveillons son évolution à
travers aussi des drones et des images
satellites donc tout ça ça permet de
nous donner plus de connaissances encore
plus de données scientifiques qui sont
utiles pour les reconstructions qui sont
utiles pour la planification urbaine
pour l'architecture pour tous les
métiers liés au patrimoine culturel
cette science est là elle est disponible
il faut que nous la que nous en
profitions il faut aussi que nous en
servions pour l'éducation pour la
transmission mais il faut surtout que
nous cessions de détruire ce patrimoine
et que nous le protégeons et que nous
ayons les moyens financiers politiques
juridiques de le faire pour finir vous
avez aussi annoncé la création 2024
justement dans toujours dans cette
perspective de mettre le
numérique au service du patrimoine la
mise en place d'une plateforme numérique
une genre de grandes bibliothèque qui
permettra à tout le monde autour de la
planète d'accéder au plus beau trésor de
l'humanité c'est une façon nouvelle
d'accéder au patrimoine ici même en
Grèce ils ont une expérience par exemple
différente ou il se servent de la
réalité virtuelle aussi pour donner une
image et une impression de ce qui était
cécité antique
au plus au plus fort de leur temps mais
au moins connaître aujourd'hui avoir à
disposition l'ensemble des plans des
vues pour pouvoir accéder visiter ce
patrimoine même à distance on en a fait
l'expérience aussi pendant la pandémie
de covid ou c'était finalement les
seules visites accessibles et bien on
peut avoir une bibliothèque numérique
digitale que chacun viendrait nourrir
qui pourrait aussi être quelque chose de
très participatif et qui permettrait
d'avoir cette encyclopédie numérique des
sites du patrimoine mondial
accessible à tous merci Madame la
Directrice générale de l'UNESCO Audrey
Azoulay d'avoir été notre invité merci à
vous merci de nous avoir donc exposé
votre vision sur l'avenir d'un
patrimoine mondial au service des
populations comme source de résilience
et de durabilité merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi restés sur France 24
l'information continue
[Musique]
la planète souffre la catastrophe
climatique on le sait est à nos portes
les émissions de CO2 explose les espèces
disparaissent mais dans le même temps un
mouvement de masse est en marche pour
rectifier le tir scientifique ingénieur
chef d'entreprise leader mondiaux ou
adolescents nous leur donnons une voix
dans élémentaire il y a vraiment des
solutions qui sont à déployer
élémentaires présentés par Marina Berch
à voir sur France 24 et France 24